some pairs of heroes have decades-old
rivalries
so heated it's almost a letdown when
they work together rather than fight
each other
but those rivalries aren't always based
on meaningful differences
if you don't believe us check out these
superhero rivalries that don't make any
sense
batman vs superman frank miller's
classic dark knight returns is one of
the most influential batman stories of
all time
and one of its most memorable moments
comes at the climax when batman takes on
superman in what seems like a fight to
the death
sound familiar what does that mean
of course superman had been hit with a
literal nuclear explosion and a tank
before batman threw his first punch
and a kryptonite arrow from ollie queen
during the fight
but a win is a win this was the moment
that took the aging bruce wayne from a
fallible human to a
master strategist who could take anyone
down before this story no one really
imagined that batman could present a
physical challenge to superman
but with the success of a single story
it became their default relationship
unfortunately if you think about it for
about two seconds it makes no sense
if they really took each other on
superman could blast batman with heat
vision from orbit before the caped
crusader could hop off whatever gargoyle
he was perched on
then he could freeze the ashes with his
super breath and throw it all into the
sun
the idea that batman is cool enough to
beat anyone with enough prep time
actually ignores what's really cool
about batman in the first place
if he's the guy who's smart enough to
figure out how to beat superman
then he should probably be smart enough
to figure out that he could get a lot
more crime fighting done if a flying
bulletproof
super strong farm boy was on his side
daredevil vs punisher daredevil and
punisher have
a rollercoaster relationship where they
find themselves teaming up as allies
just as much as they take each other on
as enemies
when they work together even after all
these years daredevil somehow seemed
surprised when the guy with the skull on
his chest who carries all the
military-grade weaponry tries to kill
someone
and that's when the honeymoon ends the
thing is either one of these two could
easily end their rivalry without doing
all that much
on one hand daredevil doesn't have much
of a leg to stand on here
he's ostensibly battling the punisher
because of his tendency to execute
criminals without giving them a fair
trial first
but if matt murdock really cared about
the letter of the law he probably
wouldn't spend his nights dressed up as
the devil punching out ninjas
given that frank castle is usually
portrayed as pretty meticulous in
selecting his targets
maybe just take the lighter workload as
a win and leave him to it on the other
hand
if he absolutely has to murder criminals
punisher might consider doing it
somewhere other than hell's kitchen
seriously frank daredevil doesn't really
leave manhattan that often
just go kill people in brooklyn and
you'll be fine flash
versus green lantern when kyle rainer
replaced hal
jordan as green lantern in the 90s it
was more than a little controversial
with a vocal group of fans demanding the
return of the previous green lantern
they weren't the only ones that were
looking down on kyle though they had an
ally and one of his own teammates
wally west better known as the flash
when the justice league's flagship title
was relaunched in 1997 as jla
rainer and west found themselves on the
same team and while other members of the
league had doubts about the new green
lantern
wally west was a straight-up jerk to him
for most of their time together
flash constantly trashed the new lantern
from the very first issue
often suggesting her outright saying he
wasn't worthy of his power ring
where did wally's rage come from wally
had been a superhero since he was a
child as kid flash
and was upholding a legacy that had been
passed down to him by his mentor
kyle on the other hand was literally
just handed the most powerful weapon in
the universe at random out of
desperation
without ever even paying his dues as a
sidekick he was however the only green
lantern at the time
so what exactly did the flash think he
was going to accomplish with his insults
it's not like they could have gotten a
replacement maybe he was just happy to
not be the youngest guy on the team
anymore
the thing versus man thing the man thing
and ben grimm better known to fantastic
four fans as the thing
didn't exactly have the storied rivalry
of some of the other pairs on this list
their conflict only lasted one issue but
it's worth mentioning for being one of
the most remarkably stupid reasons for
two heroes to fight the comics had ever
seen
the first issue of marvel two and one a
series where grimm teamed up with other
heroes throughout the universe
opens with bashful benjamin reading a
newspaper article
he becomes so furious that the swamp
monster has stolen the word thing
that he takes a bus to the floor to
everglades in order to beat him up for
copyright infringement
in typical comic book fashion the two
monstrous good guys wind up
teaming up to fight a super villain
instead in the end
the thing and man thing don't really
fight all that much
but just consider that in the first page
of the issue the thing is in new mexico
imagine taking a bus trip from new
mexico to florida as a giant
mostly naked monster so that you can
beat up another monster for having a
name that's kind of the same as yours
if that's what the ff considers worthy
of violence
then maybe dr doom is actually the good
guy here
superman vs shazam superman and captain
marvel
better known as shazam have a rivalry
that dates back to the 1940s
and goes well beyond the comics back
then dc
sued shazam's publisher fawcett
publications claiming that their world's
mightiest mortal was nothing but a
knockoff of the man of steel
after winning the lawsuit in the 50s dc
would license the shazam characters and
add them to their universe
where they moved their fight back onto
the page more often than not
it doesn't take a hardcore comic book
fan to figure out why this particular
rivalry doesn't make any sense
it seems mostly based on two people
beating each other up because they have
similar powers and a shared love of
capes
what's really disturbing about it though
is that shazam
is literally a child billy batson might
transform into a body that looks pretty
grown up but he's still a kid at heart
that means that superman emphasis on the
man
has spent their entire rivalry getting
into fist fights with a boy
dc may have won the lawsuit but in the
panels it's
definitely not a good look for superman
think about it
when these two fight if superman wins
then superman just beat up a kid
if superman loses then superman just got
beat up by a kid
superman should do everything he can to
avoid a fight with captain marvel
let him stay up past nine or play all
the fortnite he wants
it's worth it not to be known as the
superhero that beats up on
or gets beat up by grade schoolers
the avengers versus the defenders since
they first
gathered together on a day like no other
in 1963
the avengers have been made up of
earth's mightiest heroes
the defenders on the other hand have not
despite occasionally sharing members
including the hulk and doctor strange
the defenders have always been a second
string
team that deals with the weirder side of
the marvel universe
in other words they don't have much of a
reason to interact at all
let alone throw down in a massive
multi-issue fight
that's exactly what happened in 1973
when marvel launched a crossover event
known
as the avengers defenders war spread out
over eight issues
which would be a long story today let
alone back in the 70s
the event featured members of both teams
battling it out to capture pieces of an
artifact called the evil eye
it wouldn't be the last time they'd
fight but it was for the dumbest
possible reason
the demonic dormammu and loki
manipulated the teams
so that each one thought the others were
gathering up the evil eyes pieces for
nefarious purposes
you'd think this could all be solved if
captain america just called up doctor
strange and asked what was going on
but to be fair the defender's roster
boasted the hulk and prince namor
both of whom have occasionally been
super villains that said the actual
reason the avengers turned on their
would-be compatriots came when loki
you know the god of lies showed up at
the mansion and told them the defenders
were up to no good
since they had absolutely no reason at
all to believe that the lying liar who
hated them and wanted to destroy them
might not be telling the whole truth the
fight was on
think through it next time guys superman
vs flash
the ongoing contest between superman and
the flash
isn't the kind of violent conflict where
the characters come to blows
but it's gone on long enough to be one
of the greatest rivalries in superhero
history
ever since 1967's superman number 199
the flash and the last son of krypton
have occasionally raced because of the
question fans have wanted answered for
decades
who's faster superman or the flash it's
a good question
but with over 50 years behind us it's a
little weird that we're still
asking it since both characters count
super speed among their powers
their only power in the flash's case
they're both limited only by the
creator's imaginations
as a result the arguments in favor of
each hero have gotten truly ridiculous
the flash is fast enough to vibrate
through solid
objects but superman can't superman is
fast enough to time travel
under his own power but flash needs a
special high-tech treadmill to do it
it's weird stuff at the end of the day
though superman is bulletproof
strong enough to bench press mountains
can jump to the moon without breaking a
sweat
and shoot lasers out of his eyes that
can blow up cars
can he just let the guy with the fastest
man alive on the cover of his comic win
this
once and for all hulk vs wolverine
the absolute king of nonsensical
superhero rivalries
also happens to be one of the most
popular wolverine and the incredible
hulk
there is something undeniably cool about
the match and it really does fit with
wolverine's character
he's a small but vicious warrior set
against the biggest
strongest monster he could find it makes
for good art
and maybe even a good issue one good
issue
maybe two wolverine is a scrappy brawler
with unbreakable bones and razor sharp
claws
but he's also the kind of hero who's
frequently beaten up by
another guy with claws who's slightly
taller the hulk on the other hand has
punched out
gods lifted mountains on his back and
held his own against
every other hero in the marvel universe
on more than one occasion
wolverine isn't the guy who's really
going to go toe-to-toe with him and pick
up a victory
it's even backed up by their very first
meeting in incredible hulk number 181
when the hulk took wolverine out with
one relatively light bunk on the head
maybe stick to slugging it out with
cyclops from now on logan